I'm sure a lot of artists and rappers
came up here and they told you guys that
rings were like 20,000 40 . let's just
stop all right it's got you know say
like unless a guy has like a real rock
most of these rings are like in seven
five to ten thousand maybe fifteen if
somebody's taxing you know but whatever
yeah what up Jake you were some long
stone Playboy Tory Lanez on the rock
first piece of jewelry a necklace didn't
have my back it was just like a hollow
it's like this you know is like one of
those like I got it from Queens Coliseum
all actually Steve shot his feet in the
Queen's Coliseum well pretty much it was
like a Jesus piece but what was so
ghetto about the piece Jesus was like on
the cross but if you really looked close
at the piece he had the gun fingers up
the first time I ever did sweet like my
suede freestyle thing I was wearing a
piece these are not all my pieces I got
a lot of pieces on the bus for the
pieces that we have here I take you
through the Rings first this piece right
here it's like a baguette pinkie join me
I'm saying it fits right on the pinky
just felt like perfect moments when you
got the shame to let me get glass and
looking at that special someone that's
it
as olive taking me that's all it's
really about you for me I got this from
Ace to jeweler in the Bronx actually I
got a couple of these from a both of my
pinkie rings came from Ace originally
this was our first ring actually I got
this is the ring that's on the cover of
love the album artwork for love when I'm
like holding my hand like this I'm
inside or whatever cases right he used
to rock I think I had this one size down
has a pinky ring so I used to rocket
like this this is also the ring that I
referred to on my first album when I
said praying so big call - it big time I
was referring to this ring this is big
time if you look at it it's like the
wedding cake no had the first layer and
another layer and then they lay at the
top the whole thing is flooded with
diamonds down to the bottom
this one was 9000 these two it was 6 or
7
this ring actually was given to me by
Raphael Oh Julia gave to me for free
which is like really strange I'm saying
$7,000 ring I wear this like this
because the circle starting a circle so
it fits you know you'll never see Circle
Circle square square so anybody looking
criticizing my hands right now I know
who's going to change this was my first
like real big purchase if you feel this
yourself so you can understand we
sometimes like I before I even say the
price I need like you know really
understanding if you really look closely
you got 40 pointers inside of the middle
I bought the shamrock yellow pretty much
one in 75,000 I actually wear this one
boarded then I think any of our chains
I don't wear this chain anymore because
I'm missing my M I used to wear it on
stage and these used to slap on it
this one was 5000 that after you seal if
you look at my hand this is one of the
seals and this is one of the seals of
one umbrella we say forever umbrella
which is also to pull the line but
forever and brother just means no matter
what's going on for forever us from hand
no matter whatever anybody thinks nobody
can taking umbrella like you're not
under my pain
this was the first time I made the sale
with the fe he got the time you know the
whole border forgets get cut stones on
the nephew this is 3d as you can see at
the bottom rock yellow is very big on
detail and he right now his parkland
come on we've shown him that chain
without the eminent no no I mean here's
my thing with it right
I dropped this and I banged it on the
ground and that was a wrap I got a
change but there's something about the
fact that it's missing is kind of just
fired at me in a weird little way and I
don't ever feel in a way cuz you know
the thing about Raffaello is he's gonna
make sure that I bust out my whole thing
regardless so if something move you'll
never really you would never know you're
not gonna know this piece right here is
a very important piece to me here from
Toronto we grew up on this little girl
the bird of Toronto but for the baseball
team but then it was switched into a
boozy there's like a Uzi bird I got the
same went at it when I got this I was
like yeah I want to make sure that
there's something that I can get back to
the city that no matter where I go they
could always see this this one was 45
when I dropped talk to me that was the
first time I haven't put Rafi ellos name
and like a song shot around a yellow man
I let it drip drip and he put it on the
back of the gene shot the Rafi yellow
I'm good
this piece right here is the Morton Salt
Lake but what's special about it and why
I also had this piece tatted is because
it's not actually about the Morton Salt
Lake every time I saw that little bit
when I was younger it was always this
lady who seemed like she was caught in
the storm but she was always covered by
the umbrella we not salty over here
about all the salt has spilt out this
one was big too these are all my links I
rock from size to size because they vary
just take that right here these ones
30-point is people don't realize about
the links that are hanging it off of
chance there's their damn they're more
expensive than the chains are if your
[ __ ] is ten pointers most likely if this
around your neck is gonna cost you
$10,000 if mission is 24s fly you'll
cross your eyes damn you're like kind of
like that this is a scarf well oh this
is the big boy I'd only just push down
but you got it really look in the middle
and a bust down I realize there's like
40 pointers in each of these I don't
even really have too much to say about
it I think it's one of those things you
should look up and understand the value
of the watch by itself without the
Diamonds you know I'm saying it and it
realized that it's just is a big boy
watches you're flavor-wise I don't
really like to gloat about it but I'm
very happy about this much this speaks
for itself
shout out the a B jewelers he does all
my girls I could smell the bees
I heard I could do whatever I want and
they go maintain the same shine no
matter what I'll put these in right now
it's totally different person like I
don't have to let any of these pieces
for these to come alive these can change
my whole apparent sub one
I got diamond grilles and I also got all
Gold slugs I've been going through this
thing right I think I'm gonna go back to
all of the gold jewelry
don't want to be like everybody else
everybody just I like doing my own thing
but I feel like the diamonds and things
have gotten so big and mainstream that
it's cool for people to do that but I
think it's classic to always have things
that are just pure cold right now you
know this is very minimal this is just
what we had a spread up but I got rest
of my pieces in the toy bus